on you Kip I mean that they are
definitely trying to tap into people's
sense of discontent that I talked about
I don't think they have the right
solutions I think if the question on the
ballot paper next Thursday the biggest
question which it is for me I believe is
how do you run this country in a
different way so it doesn't just favor
the richest in our society UKIP's
answers mr. Faraj saying he wants to
keep the flame of Thatcherism burning
you want bigger cuts than the Tories he
wants to charge people to see their GP I
don't think there's a solution so I
think they definitely try to tap into
the discontent I think we've got better
solutions to the discontent there is and
to the feeling people have about the way
the country is run is he a racist
Nigel Faraj personally I don't think so
I think his remarks that he made
yesterday which people will have maybe
seen were deeply offensive I doubt not
wanting Romanians moving next door yes
those were insulting and offensive
remarks and he shouldn't have made
though they were racist well look I
think that they were racial slur but I
don't particularly think of Nigel Rogers
a racist himself so look I think they
were inappropriate and wrong and and
offensive and you shouldn't and he
shouldn't have made those remarks I've
been careful in this campaign not to
characterize him personally as a racist
I don't know him very well I've only met
him once but but I don't think of him
that way but I certainly think they were
they were wrong but there are some
racists in UK pound that well look for
example earlier on in the campaign there
was somebody who said something deeply
offensive about Lenny Henry that was
clearly a racist not just a racist
rather deeply kind of deeply racist
thing to say and that that person was I
think got rid of but you know I think
you could have do have to look very
carefully at who they have as candidates
and who's in there who's in their team